[Music]
Vietnamese food is bountiful in Portland
from feh to bond me it's hard to miss
but among your classic Vietnamese
restaurants there is one tiny place that
makes soups from different regions of
Vietnam that you can't find anywhere
else outside the country how that place
came to be involves the CIA and is one
hell of a journey you know it allows
story my name is William vu I'm from
South Vietnam I am the owner with my
ride the Rho VL restaurant in Portland
[Music]
I started working with the tac-19 city
tour I know many thing you know I know
the interpreter translator and then I
become better intelligent a joke by the
time the u.s. pulled out of the Vietnam
War in 1973 William was put in jail by
the communist regime he would spend the
next ten years of his life in prison the
communist government confiscated my
house the car and money in the mail
every day we do very very heavy labor
war and many people know get killed
after being released
it took William six years to reunite
with his family who settled in Portland
away from his homeland and missing the
comforts of home cooking he had an idea
in a normal restaurant they make the big
pan of broad and they use that brought
to do many different missions but here
we make variable shot for each stop only
six days a week
William and his wife Christina come in
and make two distinct soups from scratch
each soup representing a different part
of Vietnam that's it
a two item menu that changes daily and
by early afternoon they sell out died
and my wife come here 5:45 every morning
starting cooking and preparing for the
food court is up for the prom my wife
didn't get out the cooking for 5:00 a.m.
wake up six days a week
complex broths from scratch people half
the rage wouldn't be able to last long
so how are they still going because of I
woke up came I want to retire
[Music]
No Oh night Oh lalalalalala the Matane
on our own vamos a tratar something
about New Zealand eighty thousand faces
across the busy mackerel Spanish okay
before we go any further
this is absolutely it's the small brown
and black bird whose nest are a highly
sought-after delicacy here in the
Philippines that people eat them in a
soup called well bird's nest soup
typically these nests are found a high
high up on cliffs super hard to get you
and we've been taco Muslims in thousand
or five but the very deep think it out
Sunday so when these burglars n Eddie
didn't kick them out instead he gave him
half his home down similar salami
tomato be thought 1993 don't see us a
first floor now behind the Sun for
Priscilla
[Music]
sent occasional epoxy I will be rabid
known and ten minutes twenty minutes to
be laggy parents ago so they boil it add
some veggies a bit of meat and voila
bird's nest soup
it'll also be noon Katrina picked off a
shark in an epic tour la la fashion
[Music]
problem Alamitos armenia million a pop
insane or nella young a merino pnina
father mental or big snack for my path
of salem only buying the kaya
understandably so some people they just
can't appreciate the smell of 80,000
birds worth of droppings but Eddie in
the swiftlets have an arrangement
relation and even a subframe delicacy
and eternal children a kat aruba hi
param borders inaba eirin de la Frontera
militant
[Music]
[Music]
his approval to the demonym under a snow
machine Hamner freakin under ottoman era
would receive in the mail here chairman
Rodino marijuana has include a wonder to
know Graham egg a dream
Emira
[Music]
Iannetta manila roasted in Toledo
Christian Tatum M asam Hannover Germany
de bernalillo so queer Madonna body
camera bodies opposite as HondaJet ago
open abysmal didn't forget
una de janeiro hominem my channel is a
terrible procure messenger assisted a
secondary route leading to a del agua
precision and a person under Code Orange
NJ Pelham which Italians opposite the
domani jojoba acai berries can you see
can you model to represent the Romani
disappear the otaku the paper Malaysian
air to burn and burn ago we were to
reject remain was a late night
resistance to new report citizen down
artisan an assistant at the mannequin
addendum one virtual unit over my body
personal and secularism have weekly this
reason who knew the problem or just for
her walk youngji basil neutralizes real
cookie body from the latter over war for
a vote in general become a handout man
this is President of Ireland
j-john boxing today Rosalyn truly
requested the eternities America seek
his approval
McLean them they are it's 107 sale
mexican-american area including muscle
takeuchi junko TV some some ago
predominant kurama tengu mercenary
citizen volt another usual origin the
reason eternal so what we see the total
time taken is located in even translate
a melon to fatal errors another boost
immunity
[Music]
some people associate instant noodles
with broke college students but instant
ramen wasn't created for a bunch of
hungry 20 year olds the man who invented
them was much more ambitious he set out
to solve a hunger crisis in Japan after
World War two food shortages plagued
Japanese cities so the u.s. supplied
wheat flour and encouraged the Japanese
to make bread one man named Momofuku
Ando didn't understand why his people
would make bread instead of noodles
something that was already part of their
culture on dude decided to take matters
into his own hands and create a new
ramen made to last he spent a year
trying to figure out how to preserve the
noodles he needed a non perishable tasty
and easy recipe but it was a challenge
to maintain the robust flavors and
unique texture that most people were
accustomed to it wasn't until his wife
was making dinner one night
and he threw some noodles in a bowl of
hot tempura oil that he realized flash
frying the noodles was the answer he had
been looking for this method not only
dehydrated them it left small
perforations that allow the noodles to
recut quickly and there you have it
instant ramen noodles became an instant
success undos products gained notoriety
when he introduced the packaged ramen in
the 1950s and later cup noodles in 1978
his company began selling upwards of 40
billion units every year and Momofuku
Ando became a culinary icon in Japan so
the next time you heat up a cup of
instant noodles remember you're slurping
down a little piece of history
[Music]
unless you're from New Orleans you will
not know nothing about hangover hotline
I feel like my head is going to explode
can I please have some of your soup yes
I got that hangover care I'm on my way
[Music]
my name is chef Linda green I am called
the Yakima lady
yeah commuters when a New Orleans
best-kept secret it's a noodle soup yeah
Camille was classified as a poor man
dish it is Chinese and African American
fusion it's good for the soul
it's good for a hangover okay oh my god
when it hits the time it goes to the
brain and then it come back to the
tongue and tell me more my mother was a
cafeteria technician I was a cafeteria
technician to my mom and my grandmother
used to cook I could me and she always
did tell me that I may be able to one
day to use it and she was right when
Katrina hit everyone lost their jobs I
needed a job after all it's my job with
the school I was catering and I was
selling how can we add a lot of
festivals in the city I won
gumbo festival I want sushi festival
I've been winning a lot I've just been
very persistent and consistent with this
young man and it became popular and the
phone was ringing of the everybody used
to see whether I can be later that's how
I got that name you know people from all
the little bit work called me there's a
hotline girl that deliver or some or
come and pick it up I went out on a fake
and I never looked back
I love my city all I'm not gonna tell
you a word about I love my city my name
god no because hanger is very common in
New Orleans
oh yeah Camille is the best remedy for
new all inside Eddy
everyone called it pulls over I just
love what I do I love cooking I love for
someone to enjoy my food and I love for
them to come to me and tell me
everything was beautiful
[Music]